it's okay good afternoon
uh thanks joining us let's uh let's get
going so my name's Simon Brown I'm
independent consultant specializing
software architecture and the purpose of
the session is to talk about C4 models
as code who is using C4 here
that's a good chunk of you but not all
of you excellent so this is going to be
like a 20-minute talk with the rest of
it as being kind of live demos and stuff
so
architecture diagrams are historically
very very bad I'm sure you've all seen
diagrams like this kicking around your
SharePoint Confluence Pages whiteboards
Etc
uml fixes a lot of these problems but
nobody seems to want to use uml these
days why I have literally heard all of
the reasons you can possibly imagine
people tell me that you'll be seen as
old if you use uml the tooling's
horrible it's a waste of time it's not
expected in agile etc etc it's worth
noting that most of these are not true
so enter the C4 model the C4 model you
can find on c4model.com and this is
really the premise behind the entirety
of the C4 model if you don't want to use
uml or argument or SML all those other
kind of standardized formulas notations
but you still need to draw some
architecture diagrams and you want to
use boxes and arrows try to do so in a
structured way and make sure your
notation is self-describing that's
essentially the key principle behind C4
C4 is essentially two things number one
it's a hierarchical set of abstractions
the largest of these abstractions I'm
going to call a software system
a software system is to be honest with
you it's the hardest of these
abstractions to easily Define but
essentially what I mean by a software
system is something that we are
delivering as a team it's something that
we can see the internal implementation
details of is something that we have
responsibility for we're supporting Etc
if we look inside these things I'm
calling software systems I'm going to
say they are made up of one or more
containers I know Docker is a thing
forget docker like this has nothing to
do with Docker I apologize I got the
name first I know that's totally
irrelevant because dock is way more
popular by container I basically mean an
application or a data store
so the software systems we build are
made up of applications and data stores
react on the browser angular on the
browser ASP or net MVC on the server
spring boot on the server PHP python
Ruby Etc running on a server that's what
I mean by app
datastore is your relational database
schema it's a folder on a file share
it's an Amazon S3 bucket it's a Azure
blob store etc etc
if we look inside these things I'm
calling containers
specifically the code focused containers
the applications I'm going to say they
are made up of components components is
a massively overloaded word I get that
but by components I want to be very
something very specific a component here
is a grouping of related functionality
hopefully a nice clean World find
interface into that functionality
running inside a container so in this
set of abstractions the component is not
the separately Deployable item
the container is the separately
Deployable thing
and if you look inside components I'm
going to say they are made up of code
level elements so if you are building a
c-sharp component when you zoom inside
it it's made up of enums classes in
faces Java same thing C plus plus same
thing if you are building a JavaScript
component now it's objects and functions
F sharp Pascal functions so really that
bottom level represents the constructs
we have in the languages that we're
using and that's the four levels of
abstraction a software system is made up
of one or more containers containers
contain components that's where the name
comes from and components are made up of
code level elements
once you have that set of abstractions
you can then move on to the second thing
which is a hierarchical set of diagrams
so C4 is named after the hierarchical
set of diagrams and there are four of
them the clue is in the name here system
context containers components and code
and the four levels of diagrams map onto
those four levels of abstraction and
it's a kind of zoom in zoom in Zoom
thing zoom in thing as you get further
down the stack
the concept here is kind of diagrams as
Maps so I live in Jersey in the Channel
Islands and if you open up Google Maps
and you do a search for Jersey you are
going to get that picture
if you know where Jersey is because
you've seen Bergerac
yeah I knew that would work
um very big in the 80s for those of you
who are too young if you know where
Jersey is this is great you can find
where the airport is and the beaches and
the major roads and all that sort of
thing if you've never heard of Jersey
because you're too young or you never
saw Bergerac you have to pinch to zoom
out and eventually if you zoom out far
enough Jersey complete disappears
because it's tiny on the flip side we
can zoom in zoom and zoom in and we can
drop into something like Google Street
View and Google Street View is a
one-to-one mapping with the real world
when the photos were taken so it's
different levels of maps that
essentially allow us to explore
differently the diagrams the software
architecture diagrams are essentially
the same thing it's different levels of
diagrams that allow us to tell different
stories to different audiences though
context diagram as you'll see shortly is
quite technology agnostic and as we dive
deeper we get more and more technical
details
so as we progress down the stack of
diagrams it's more towards Architects
and Developers
I'm going to explain the top two levels
of diagrams before we get into the the
kind of tooling demos because it's it's
useful to know what these are so the top
level diagram is a system context
diagram and the system context diagram
basically says here's your system in the
middle and here are the things around it
in terms of people and other Software
System integration points so in other
words in order to draw a system context
diagram these are the questions you need
to ask
what's the scope of the thing we're
building what features sit inside our
box what features sit outside of our box
in the rest of the environment who is
using the system we are building actors
roles personas real people what types of
things are they doing and what system
integration points do we need to support
answer those questions and you can draft
up something like a context diagram
this is our context diagram from one of
the workshops that I run the red box the
Financial Risk system is the thing that
this team we're designing
they've added a bit of detail there and
they've correctly identified a couple of
user types and some system integration
points so most of these systems are
provided by the environment around it so
that's an example system context diagram
it's people and software systems
as developers we want more details so
now we can do the pinch to zoom movement
and we can drop down to level two and
draw a container diagram
this is a different set of questions
essentially because it's a different
diagram showing different things so the
questions are what are the major
Technology Building Blocks in other
words what are the applications and data
stores that make up this thing that
we're building what are the
responsibilities of those applications
and data source and how do they
communicate
answer those questions and you can draft
up something like a container diagram
so you'll notice the big red box has now
been kind of zoomed in and we're showing
the applications and data source the C4
model containers that sit inside that
red boundary
here we have some spring apps some
JavaScript apps and some data stores
and it's a nice diagram it's got some
responsibilities it's got some tech
choices some protocols it's just a nice
summary of the overall software
architecture
a couple of points to note the C4 model
is notation independent
a lot of people who might have done C4
in the past will tell you that it's blue
and gray boxes that's not the case you
can use any colors other colors are
available you can also use other
notations I don't I've got a whole round
back color coding honestly pin me
afterwards you can also use alternative
notation so if you want to use uml as
your notation that's absolutely fine so
there's nothing preventing you using uml
archimate to SML for your C4 diagrams
why because C4 is two things it's a set
of abstractions and a set of diagram
types it doesn't tell you anything about
notation
so tooling this is the big question most
people ask me what tooling do I
recommend if you go to c4model.com
there's a tooling link and I've tried to
list all of the tools that I have found
that provide some degree of specific
support for the C4 model
and they're broadly speaking two
categories there are diagramming tools
and modeling tools
so most people use general purpose
modeling tools quick show of hands who's
using Vizio draw.io diagrams.net
omnograph or lucidchart glyphy
yeah and the rest it's massively it's
massively used so this is kind of most
people's first choice of a diagram tool
these tools are fantastic but I don't
recommend them for drawing architecture
diagrams especially if you're going to
use the C4 model for reasons I'll become
clear in a second
reason number one
if you open a diagram in Vizio or
diagrams.netdraw.io it doesn't know what
you're doing
those tools just see shapes boxes and
arrows so a system context diagram
really only should show people and
software systems there's nothing
preventing you when you're using Vizio
adding things like components to a
system context diagram
so this little thing down here really
shouldn't be there there are not many
rules in C4 but that's one of them
but Vizio can't stop you
if you want a system context diagram and
a container diagram in a tool like Visio
you do this by opening two tabs and
creating two diagrams
one of the things you'll notice with C4
is you end up duplicating things like
people and software systems across your
various layers of detail
how do you do that Visio you copy and
paste to a different worksheet a
different tab what happens if you rename
the person well now you've got two names
are these two different people or are
they the same person and we just forgot
to change one of the names so the tool
can't help you here it doesn't realize
that two boxes are the same thing
this is pretty self-explanatory if you
try and Export these things to text to
stick them and get you get an utter mess
this leads on to the next thing which is
they're hard to diff if you change the
name of something many of these file
formats don't show you that change very
easily
and most of these tools don't have any
sorts of automation apis with draw.io
diagrams.net there is a way to give it a
CSV file and you can have Auto
generation diagrams but that's pretty
much it most of the other tools don't
provide much in the way for automation
these tools are also a pain in the ass
we've all done this
um yeah
you notice this text mostly fits and
you're like you know should I add it
like a couple of lime Blake line breaks
line breaks in there and if you do you
have to like change the size of the
boxes and re-center everything it's a
bit of a pain and that Line's not
straight
it's one pixel out and you know what
happens you kind of nudge it and it's
still one pixel out the other way
ah dear so
back in the heady days of the pandemic
uh 2020 sometime I forget when the
thoughtworks tech radar blipped diagrams
as code as a thing that people should
look at adopting trialing
diagrams as code is essentially a way to
create diagrams from text so rather than
opening up a tool like Visio and
dragging and dropping using your mouse
basically what you're doing is you're
writing some text and you're using
tooling to generate diagrams for you
from that text definition the most
popular tools in this space are probably
plant uml and mermaid there are some
others but predominantly those are the
two two tools you'll see people using
diagrams this code is awesome because
it's easy to author it's just text as
developers we like text we have lots of
tooling and IDs to support text there
are plugins for things like vs code that
do completion and intellisense these are
texts so they're easy to do for easy
diversion control and many of these
tools have automated CLI type
environments so you can automate these
and push them into your CI CD build
process so you can have automatically
automatically generated architecture
diagrams
the most popular tool in terms of kind
of diagrams as code for C4 is called C4
plant uml so this is plant uml plus some
macros that some people are built on top
and rather than talking about boxes and
arrows and rectangles C4 plant URL adds
some macros that you plug into your
plant your mail file and now you talk
about person and system and relationship
so this is like if you like it's a a
more domain specific language that talks
about C4 diagrams
problem with diagrams as code in most
cases is that if you want two diagrams
you need two text files
exactly the same way with Visio you need
two tabs two worksheets
if you want to start to copy and pasting
elements because you want them included
on both diagrams you have to make sure
that that the lines are in both text
files if you rename one of those things
you have to make sure you rename it in
both text files now things like plantuml
do allow you to do
exclamation mark include so you can
potentially pull out Snippets include
them from multiple files and we can use
our tooling to do Global search and
replace across a folder full of files
but fundamentally if you want two
diagrams it's two files see the
responsibility to keep the files in sync
is on your shoulders
I want to change the narrative so I'm
old apparently back in the back in the
early 2000s late 90s I guess there was
this whole thing about modeling
tools like rational rows who's used
rational rows
spot old people thank you
Russia Rose is like this big expensive
modeling tool and it was very powerful
it was very ugly as well but it was very
powerful and and there's lots of good
stuff you can do with things like a
modeling tool but when I say modeling
these days people go uh rational Rose no
like we do Agile Russian Rose is a relic
from the waterfall days and it's
unfortunate because
a model is essentially just a centrally
defined dictionary of things and then
you can reuse those things across
multiple diagrams that's it
that the power of having a modeling tool
is is immense
and it solves many of the problems I've
just already spoken about
so
most of my income
is is through flying around the world
and running workshops and I wasn't able
to do that during covert because I got
stuck on my Island oh it's not my
Islands but I just got stuck on the
island so I basically did a lot of
Surfing which is quite fun but you can
only do that so much hours a day but I
created a bunch of tooling to solve many
of these problems and the tool I'm going
to show you today is called the
structurizer DSL
this is an open source text-based domain
specific language specifically targeted
and designed to create C4 model diagrams
what you're doing here is you're
crafting up a single definition of
everything and you're using tooling to
automatically generate two diagrams off
the back of the things contained in that
text file in that model so this is
fundamentally a text based model based
approach to diagramming
and I've tried to make it nice and lean
and lightweight with a bunch of
extensibility points I'll talk about
later
this
little snippet here the screenshot I'll
let you read it this is the problem with
tools like plantuml
it's nice and easy to get started but
once you want to start spanning and
scaling across teams or you want to
model your whole Enterprise your whole
portfolio of systems you lead at least a
lot of duplication and it becomes quite
complicated so I see people jumping on
C4 plant uml because it's easy but they
run into issues very very quickly so
that's another reason why I kind of put
this tool in together
so essentially this is models as code or
rather C4 models as code I'm also
calling this diagrams as code two just
to differentiate it with things like
plant uml
um change for 2023 is that everything
I'm going to show you is completely open
source so I went through a big exercise
in January February March the theater to
open source literally the entirety of
this this tooling and there are lots of
plug-in points as well so the
structurizer DSL is open source it's all
on GitHub that is a wrapper around an
existing Library called structurizer for
Java I wrote actually five plus years
ago there's a bunch of command line
tools that I'll show you quickly which
is also also open source there's a thing
called structurizer light to it so which
is a it's a spring boot application that
that comes pre-packaged as a Docker
image that you can use and boot up and
view diagrams as an on-premises
installation and there's a bunch of
export utilities for different formats
so I'm going to kind of show you all of
that stuff
so enough of the slides let's jump into
the demo so uh to show you that I'm not
cheating
here is my desktop which is currently
empty which is a result in itself so I'm
going to start up structurizer Lite
which is this spring boot thing provided
as a docking container
structurizer lights when you start it up
you you do two things number one is a
volume Mount and number two is a port
map so it's just a bog standard Docker
thing so I'm going to start structurizer
light that script is going to do a port
map to Locos 8080 and the parameter I'm
going to pass here is the volume Mount
so I'm going to mount
a folder that doesn't yet exist on my
desktop called NDC and pass it to
structurizing light
so we start up structure as a light and
hopefully this all runs
we go to the web browser
we go localhost 8080
and we have drumroll please diagram
so this is structurizer lights now
running in the web browser it's a Java
spring boot app with a whole bunch of
JavaScript SVG stuff running in the
browser on the client side so here we
have a user somehow using a software
system
so where did this come from if we go
back here now we can see this NDC folder
has been created and inside is a DSL
file
this is the structurizer DSL
what we're doing here is we're defining
a workspace a workspace is essentially a
wrapper for two things a model and a set
of views the model is where we Define
our people our software systems our
containers our components
so we're here we're defining a person
with the name user we're defining a
software system with the name Software
System and we're defining a link a
relationship between the user and the
software system with a description of
users so that's my model
then we are defining a system context
view from the C4 model we are defining a
system context View for the software
system
and this is just a diagram identifier
we're saying it includes star
what's include stardew include star says
includes the software system
and include everything that is linked or
has a connection to that Software System
and apply automatic layout so that gives
us this diagram
and I can do things like so
I don't like automated layout
I think it's useful if you have diagrams
with like three four five six maybe 10
elements but in many cases automatic
layout doesn't actually work very well
so I built this tooling with manual
layout in mind so let's show you that
I'm going to comment this out save it go
back here refresh now we have a
bunchable toolbar options and we can
start moving boxes around
so this is how I prefer to use the
tooling myself you can start breaking
lines and changing line routing and all
that sort of stuff and it will save it
here
if I rename this
thing here to be called a business user
save it go back here
so there's some there's an algorithm
built into all this tooling that tries
to retain the layout that you created
manually
some of you might be thinking well hang
on a second
where is the layout where are the XY
coordinates for those boxes the answer
is they're in this Json document so this
Json document is really the canonical
data structure used by all of the
structurizer tooling and it's really
just a different version of that same
information so here we can see all the
people defined in our model here's the
business user and a bunch of properties
here is the software system
and here if I keep scrolling down we can
see things like the elements there X Y
coordinates versus on links that sort of
thing
so what you do now is you take this
whole folder you commit it to source
code control along with the script to
start structurizer light and now anybody
can bring this up on demand and see this
exact same diagram
so let's go back here let's turn on
automatic layout because it works better
for demos
I'm going to go back here refresh now we
have our automatic layout version
so the first problem we have this
diagram is that it's just two very
boring gray boxes so so let's add a bit
of pizzazz to these diagrams how do we
do that Pizzazz yeah I'm going to turn
on tool tips and you can embed a bunch
of metadata inside the DSL and add your
own metadata that shows up on the
tooltips
so you'll notice here that this business
user element has two little things in
text this is element and person these
are text based tags the software system
has an elements tag and the Software
System tag the person has an element tag
and a person tag
if for any of you who are kind of
front-end developers you know HTML this
is like CSS classes for your HTML
elements
and what we can do is we can add styles
for these text-based tags
so let's do that and change some things
what I'm going to do now here is add a
Styles section
let's move that up a bit I'm going to
create an element style for the elements
tag so this is going to get all elements
and let's go backgrounds
green
color white
go back here refresh so now we have
white on Green
if we want to change the shape of this
business user to a person what we can do
is we can do the same thing we can say
create an element style for the person
tag
shape person
there we go
so that's a really nice way to start
styling all these things consistently so
imagine we've drawn our wonderful
looking context diagram and we're super
happy and now we want to zoom in to that
software system and draw the container
diagram
as I said with tools like plant uml now
you spin up a second text file off you
go with this tooling what you do is you
go up to here
you open up a set of curly braces
and you start typing away so let's have
a web application
which is going to be a C4 model
container
and that's going to be called web app oh
my goodness I can't type at this angle
let's have a database why not
classic architecture of course
so we have found a database sitting
inside the software system I know I've
just drawn all of your architecture
diagrams in one go thank you
and we're going to say there is a link
from the user to the web app and we'll
say users as well please don't need to
users yourself and we're going to say
there's a link from the web app to the
database and we'll say reads from and
writes to
so if I save this and go back here and
refresh what's going to happen
nothing the answer is correct nothing
because we've added elements to our
model but we've not created A View to
surface to present those elements and
turn them into a diagram so how do we do
that what we do is we take this block
we copy paste it
we're going to change that to container
so we want to create a container diagram
for that software system so that's fine
this needs to change because it's a
diagram identifier
include Styles fine so what includes
star here does is it says include all of
the containers inside that software
system in this case the web app and the
database and anything that links to them
so that'll hopefully bring in the person
as well and apply automatic let so now
we can save it go back here
so now you'll see this little plus
symbol here if we double click this now
we get to The Container diagram
showing the user has a link to the web
app and the web app has a link to the
database
so a couple of things I want to show you
I've defined this link this uses link
between the user and the web app
and this link at the upper level between
the user and the software system
and this is really a um it's a violation
dry isn't it don't repeat yourself we've
essentially repeated the same
information twice to have that link shop
on two levels of detail
I don't want to do that I want this tool
to be smart and help me do things so
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
delete one of these lines now you have
to delete the correct line and let's
hope I get this right I'm going to
delete this one
I'm going to go back here save it
so this is the line that's now defined
in this text file between the user and
the web app
that one there if I go back here that
line still exists
so this is a feature called implied
relationships because there's a link
between the user and the web application
and the web application is a container
inside the bigger high level Software
System abstraction there is an implied
or an implicit link between the user and
the software system so this tooling
knows it's missing and it kind of adds
it for you and this is all customizable
you can turn it on turn it off customize
it however you like to but it's a really
nice feature that
stops you having to write lots and lots
and lots of different relationships
what I want to show you now
let's make this a database shape because
why not if I go back to tooltips so this
web application has an element tag and a
container tag and so does this database
in order to style just the database
we're going to need to add our own
custom tag to that database element so
then we can add a style for it so let's
do this in two goes we're going to take
this database
tags let's just say database so now if I
save this go back refresh
tool tips on Hover now we can see
there's a database tag there and now we
can do essentially the same thing again
we can create an element style for the
database tag shape is database no it's
not a cylinder
if we now want to make all containers a
different color we can do that as well
so they're like CSS Styles these Styles
kind of cascade and override so we can
create an element style for the
container and we can say background
C green does that work in HTML let's
find out
yeah so we have different slightly
different color greens for the
containers one of the things I said at
the start was uh if you're going to use
boxes and arrows make sure you do it in
a structured way that's what the
abstractions bring you and try to make
your notation self-describing so what's
missing from this diagram is a diagram
key explaining what the different shapes
and colors are but I I have your back
there we go so this tooling will
automatically generate you a diagram key
based upon the tags you have on your
elements and the styles that you have in
your DSL file
and there's lots of shapes and colors
and Border styles that you can do and
you can also start relationships with
dashed arrows and solid arrows for you
know synchronous versus asynchronous
unless you went to Sam Newman's talk and
you're really confused now but there's
lots of stuff you could you can kind of
do here I saw it last week in craft
confused it was fantastic
so that is
the structurizer DSL and structurizer
light in a nutshell
so I'm going to show you a few more
things I'm going to open up a new tag
and go to structuralize.com DSL this is
um it's a little demo page on my host of
cloud service what I'm going to do is
I'm going to take this
I'm going to paste it into this left
hand side and click render and this is
going to give us the same diagrams that
I just showed you with the structurizer
light tooling so if you want to try any
of this tooling out structrise.com DSL
is the place to go
I've also built a bunch of exports uh
utilities and that's one of the nice
things about the structuralized DSL it's
rendering tool independent so I showed
you my structurizer light tooling which
is an in-browser JavaScript SVG
rendering engine
I've also built a bunch of tools that
allows you to export your diagrams to
plant uml
so this is a plant gml version of that
same container diagram here's the plant
you melt text it gives you that will
also generate you a key
okay there is also an export for C4
plant uml so by default C4 plant tuml
uses the
standard in air quote it's a gray and
blue boxes but we all know that's not
the case you can change this so if I go
here and I go
properties don't worry if you can't read
this C4 plantuml dot tags true and click
render
go back here this will hopefully be
different now yeah so there's a way you
can customize these things it's all it's
all open source you can do what you want
to there's also an exports that I
pre-built for mermaid so this is a
mermaid version of that same diagram
there's a DOT for graphis version if you
have Dynamic diagrams so this tooling
also supports the dynamic diagrams and
deployment diagrams a bunch of other
things as well so this is an example of
this tooling being rendering tool
independent this is the demo page but
the uh the CLI tooling I built basically
integrates all of this tooling into one
place so what you can do is you can go
to a command line let me shut this down
you can say run the CLI we're going to
do an export the workspace is going to
be that file on my desktop
NDC workspace.dsl and the format is
going to be plantuml
what have I done
users Simon desktop NDC workspace what
have I done
it's there
No it should work on the on the other
one
oh you love demos
the file adds that definitely exists
doesn't it
okay so my tools doesn't work
there we go but if it did work you could
export using the CLI
um
into various formats I have no idea why
it doesn't work anyway moving on so what
I'm going to show you now is another
example structuralized light against a
different example hopefully this will
work
so the example diagrams you'll see on
c4model.com
are the uh the setup diagrams for an
internet banking system so I'm going to
boot those up for you now in struct size
light
so starting at the top this is the
system landscape diagram you'll see on
these on the C4 model.com website double
click get to the context diagram double
click container diagram double click
component diagram so those are the kind
of the basic C4 diagrams with lots of
new Styles and shapes and things this
also does dynamic diagrams so if you
want to show how specific use case or
story or feature works you can kind of
Step through it's all nicely animated
and this also does deployment diagrams
where you can show how things are
deployed onto infrastructure so here
we've got the web app and the API app
running in Tomcat on a Docker container
on a developer laptop so you can build
up all this model using the DSL as well
tool tips
etc etc
so that structurizer light
I'm going to do now is shut down
structurizer light and show you another
tool called C4 VIs
against that same
example
now
this is another open source tool it's
kind of like um a structurizer light
clone
it doesn't always work on my laptop
and I don't know why but we'll give it a
go
it sometimes gets stuck here
I'm going to suggest this one's not
going to work
um
I I don't know why it doesn't work and
when it doesn't work you have to go into
Docker desktop
dashboard and you have to kill it
and then have try again
and then it'll get stuck again and I'll
have to repeat the same thing and we'll
abandon this one but essentially this is
a structurizer like clone it's an
in-browser thing but it's not using my
JavaScript SVG renderer it's using plant
uml as its renderer so let's let's
select the office it's not going to work
so that's C4 first you can find it on
GitHub I'm going to show you another
another tool called the structurizer
sites generator I'm going to point it at
the same
folder the big Bank example
is this one that will have to work
so this is structuralized as a site
generator what this is doing is
generating you a kind of HTML micro site
based upon the information in that
workspace if you've embedded markdown
and ascii.documentation as a part of
that workspace they'll be rendered in
your browser what you can do is you can
go systems
is a banking system so you get your
description of the internet banking
system and it kind of has all of the
views in one place so again this is kind
of like structurizer light but it's
showing you the same information in a
different in a different kind of
organizational structure so here's the
context view for that internet banking
system
and they've hyperlinked it so if I click
that we can go to The Container diagram
if we click this we can go to the
component diagram etc etc so this is
using the C4 plant uml renderer so again
this is another way to kind of have all
this information displayed and rendered
in a different way which is which is
quite nice
so let me shut that one down now
I'm going to boot up structuralizer
lights again against yet another example
let's go there
so something you do here is you can
embed markdown and ASCII doc
documentation
as a part of this whole thing so then
you have all of your documentation and
your diagrams all in one place commit
that whole folder to source code control
along with the source code and kind of
all your art acts are sitting in one
place
so if I go back to here and go
structuralize the light
this is a different example for anyone
who's been in my workshop I use a
Financial Risk system as our case study
this is like an example piece of
documentation for that Financial Risk
system so this is markdown documentation
now being rendered in your web browser
let me show you the source so you know
I'm not cheating so this is the folder
this is the workspace file same thing
we've already seen before we're defining
a software system for the Financial Risk
system this exclamation mark docs
basically says include all of the
markdown and ascii.documentation in that
docs folder
that docs folder looks like this it's
just standard markdown
just double click that really should
know there we go okay so this is just
standard markdown with the exception of
this little thing here which is an image
which is it's an image but I'm using the
syntax embed and then that's the context
diagram from that workspace so that
diagram identifier I showed you before
is the reason
um that thing there that's the reason I
have to be unique so you can include
these things later
how large is this file
foreign
there's a way you can do includes and
workspace extensions and there's a way
to modernize these these files as well
to to prevent them getting larger no
I'll talk briefly about that later
so here we're basically saying include
the docs and uh yeah this is all
rendered in the browser so you have a
nice way to include diagrams inside your
markdown documentation this is the live
version so it also has things like the
diagram key and you can you can click to
see the diagram etc etc you can go full
screen
so that's a nice way to include those
live architecture diagrams potentially
with additional metadata behind the
tooltips as a part of your markdown and
ASCII documentation and it's all full
text searchable etc etc
so that's
um that's documentation is anybody using
architecture decision records here
oh that's only a small number so if
you've not looked at architecture
decision records uh thoroughly recommend
it it's a fantastic way to start
capturing the architecture decisions
that you're making on a potentially
daily weekly basis
there's lots of tooling out there to
support adrs and ADR is typically a
single markdown or ASCII doc file
describing a single decision like we
decided to use this Frame this version
of a framework for these reasons
check them in source connection control
and then order of your decisions are in
one place the problem with adrs is that
once they go into source code control
they're forgotten about you just have a
folder full of markdown or ascii.files
so what I did with this tooling is I
same thing
you can also
say exclamation mark adrs adrs So in
this case it says pull in all the
architecture decision records in the
adrs folder and here we have a folder
full of adrs this is all created using
nap prices ADR tools tool so that's what
an ADR looks like
and this tooling structurizer light will
render them for you in the browser so
here we have a nice summary of all of
the architecture decision records it's
all text searchable we can scroll
through them etc etc so this is a really
nice way to search and visualize your
adrs one of the things you can do with
ADR is you can start superseding
previous adrs so therefore what you're
doing is you're actually building up a
network a graph of adrs and and the
addition part the decision parts
as it progresses through your
um through your delivery life cycle
you can show that with this tooling so
it'll start linking things together to
show you where you've started
superseding um older versions of
decisions and things
so that's
that kind of tooling
one of the big questions I always get
with C4 and and specifically tooling as
well all your example diagrams only show
like six boxes
yes
how do you make this work for actual
systems that are more than six boxes
Okay so
let me boot up another example
and see how many Docker containers we
can get running
in our session
so I'm going to boot up another example
this is a a micro service based
architecture and hopefully Sam's not
here to tell me off if this is not true
so I'm going to open up a new tab go to
structuralize line so here we have
imagine we have a service based
architecture
what do I mean by service
so one of the things that C4 kind of
forces you to do is to get more precise
and specific with the words that you're
using although many many people talk
about talk about a micro service based
architecture in many cases an individual
micro service is is actually something
like
an API thing so maybe like a asp.net MVC
API thing talking to a SQL Server
relational database schema
so maybe those two things are what we
mean by a microservice so what this
diagram is showing you is essentially
all of the API things and all of the
database things and I'm using this
grouping to say this pair of things is
service two in this case
so imagine you have a service based
architecture here we have eight services
and I'm using different color codings
for different Services again this
diagram kind of works okay this is
created using automatic layout but you
can you can now see as we add more
services this diagram is going to get
more complicated quite quickly so how do
we solve this problem
well this diagram is showing you it's
one diagram showing eight Services what
we could do instead is draw one diagram
per service so maybe we have eight
diagrams each focused on a single
service only and that's what we can do
here so here we have the service one
diagram which is showing you service one
things coming into service one and the
things coming out of service one so it's
it's inbound and outbound dependencies
the afferent and the efferent couplings
if you want to use those terms here is
the system sorry the service 2 version
so it's things coming into service two
things coming out of service to register
and repeat for service three four five
six Etc
with a tool like Vizio how do you do
this you open up eight new tabs and now
you start copy and pasting boxes and
arrows across all those things
and then you realize you mess up
somewhere and you have to start changing
things and keep them all in sync and it
gets that absolute nightmare so this
tooling because it's model based it
means you can do some interesting stuff
so let's go back here this is the folder
the services example
so here we have it's a DSL file to
answer the question of how long is it
this is 161 168 lines
so here we're defining the software
system
this is service one so service one is
basically a grouping of the API thing
and the database thing repeat for
service two for service three for
service four for five for six for seven
you get a picture here all the
relationships so that's the model
this is the all contains version so
we're saying create a container view for
that Software System it includes star
which is including all of the containers
therefore all of the services and apply
automatic layouts this is the service
one version
so we're saying include service one
include things coming into service one
and things leaving service one so this
is a really nice way there's a nice
expression language built into the DSL
that allows you to kind of slice and
dice the model up and show different
things on different views so you could
do like include start and then exclude a
bunch of things you can say include
everything of type container if you want
to show container to container
relationships between software systems
that's easy to do with this expression
language and this is all extensible so
you can build your own Expressions if
you want to later
so in terms of how do we make this
tooling work and how do we make the C4
model work for bigger more complicated
software systems
option number one
have lots of smaller diagrams
it's all trade-offs the downside of
having lots of smaller diagrams is you
now lose some of that bigger context
and some people like having that bigger
context but of course as you will add
more services this diagram will get more
collected more complicated
so option two is to not use a
traditional diagram
I know I talk a lot about diagrams and
how to make diagrams look nice but maybe
a better option is to use a different
visualization format so if you boots up
structurizer light
and you click this magic button you'll
get
that now this is very therapeutic
this is a JavaScript d3js Force director
graph and it's essentially showing you
exactly the same information but it's
doing it in a very different format so
we're using lots of smaller nodes here
this has tooltips so if you add embedded
documentation or metadata you could see
that on this diagram you can start
clicking around things to show nearest
neighbors so if you want to say hey what
does service one have dependency on you
can use that use this exploration to
find information very quickly and
there's a quick find feature as well for
example so this is option two it's a use
of different visualization format we're
still using the same C4 types and we're
still using the same C4 diagram type but
we're visualizing it differently
that's option two
option three is to use the structurizer
CLI to do an export to another tool now
since the CLI doesn't seem to be working
for reasons I have no idea why I'm going
to cheat and I'm going to take this
example
I'm going to open up yet another tab go
to my DSL demo page
I'm going to paste it across
get the same diagram we had before there
we go
and there's the graph which is nice
we can do plantuml as well if you want
to so all of these things I've shown you
they're all renderable with other
formats but that's not what I want to
show you I want to show you this one
here so there's a tool out there called
ILO graph it's available at ilograph.com
nothing to do with me and it's a really
nice tool that helps you to explore and
visualize a hierarchical data set and of
course this is a hierarchical data set
the downside of this tooling is that the
inputs for this tool is yaml
and I can't stand here and recommend
people handcrafted yaml so I built you a
way to get from my DSL to this yaml
format which is available through the
CLI that doesn't work or through this
demo page so what you can do is we can
copy this into our clipboard to open up
yet another tab go to islegraph.com
we can go new diagram I will ignore that
we'll put mine in we'll click static
structure
so this is the same information now in
the oligraph tool
the nice thing about this tool and the
reason I like it is because it is
Interactive
so now we can start clicking around and
it kind of zooms into the thing you've
clicked on to show your scope and now
you can see kind of nearest neighbors
etc etc so this is another really nice
tool that helps you explore navigate
through memorize yourself with a larger
a large architecture
if I go back to My Demo page
and I go to the big Bank example the
internet banking system
so here's my set of diagrams for the
internet banking system same thing I can
go to the autograph export
go to autograph go new diagram go in
there delete it paste mine in minimize
that go static structure there we go so
this is another view of that internet
banking system example it's showing you
everything it's showing you people's
systems containers and components all
this kind of nested constructs and again
we can start zooming in and figure out
what's going on and clicking around so
this is a great tool for manipulating
and visualizing exploring a kind of
larger data set which is quite nice so
essentially you have lots of options you
stick with the abstractions you stick
with the the diagram types but you use
different tools to visualize them and
therefore explore them
what else did I want to show you a
couple of different things so
all of this tooling is built in Java
who's the Java developer here I'm going
to suggest this is nobody
a couple of people cool okay so for the
two Java drivers here welcome
I found my people
um
all of this tooling I've built is is
written in Java
there's a Java Library it's all on Maven
Central the DSL parser is also a Java
Library so if you have the ability to
write Java code if it's something you're
using on a regular basis you can add
yourself a dependency to my DSL parser
you can create yourself a DSL parser you
can parse a DSL file get the workspace
out this is like an in-memory
representation of the workspace and then
you can start doing things like find the
web app container and add components to
it so what you could do here is you
could craft up your high level
definition of your architecture maybe
people's software systems containers in
the DSL and then load it through the
code libraries and now start adding
components why might this be useful
maybe you want to use Java's reflection
mechanism or static allows us to go and
automatically generate a component
diagram from your real code base maybe
you want to scrape your AWS environments
your config files to pull in a config
file and generate a diagram of your AWS
environment again you can use this
tooling to do the same thing none of
that is available at the box but we're
developers we can write tooling to do
that
so if I if I run this little demo
hopefully this will work as I'm in real
trouble
yeah so here we're basically just
printing out all of the elements
in that workspace and we added this
logging component which is why it's
showing up in the in the output
so that was the demo for the two job
developers in the room
uh who's a.net developer
hey
so there is a version of this Library
called structurizer4.net it's something
I wrote a number of years ago it's
mostly up to date it mostly supports the
same features as the Java version but
there is some stuff missing it over it
is open source so you can issue pull
requests if you want to
there's no DSL parser in the.net version
but what you can do instead is you can
point it to the uh the Json version so
I'm going to change that
so the Json version is created for you
by structurizer Lite but again you could
also use the CLI to export the DSL to
the Json file now you have the Json file
you can use the.net library to load the
Json file get a workspace and then we
can do the same thing we can say find me
the Software System called Software
System find me its container called web
app and add a login component to it then
print anything out
so hopefully this will work
there we go
so now you have again a bunch of ways to
craft up a high level definition in DSL
loads the resulting workspace in your
tool of choice in this case.net and then
you can do stuff to it so this library
is built to be append only so you kind
of craft up a high level version and
then you add and append things using the
the code based libraries if you want to
so that's pretty much all of the tooling
there's a whole bunch of other stuff you
can find if you do a search for
structurizer on GitHub people have built
all sorts of tools integrate into their
build processes they built GitHub
actions to generate diagrams it's all
scriptable and again all of this stuff
is open source
so I have two slides I would like to
show you
there's a whole bunch of stuff I've not
shown you uh the first of these features
is called workspace extension something
a lot of organizations want to do is
they want to craft up a single
structurizer workspace defining all of
their people so users and all of the
software systems that exist in their
organization and then they they want
individual teams to extend this
workspace and add in the container and
component details for the systems they
are working on so this is a nice way to
do this essentially you can have a
single workspace which is your system or
service catalog and then you have every
team kind of extend it and adds their
own information I see lots of people
with these days using things like
spotify's backstage or their own
internal service catalogs again you
could build some integration that
scrapes all of your software systems and
services from backstage from your
service catalogs and then kind of you do
the drill down one C4 model set of
diagrams per team for example
there's also a way to modularize this so
if you want to have uh fragments that
you include in various places multiple
times you can do that because this
tooling is all Java based there's the
ability to write short scripts either
inline or in included files in jvm
scripting languages which is only useful
for the two people who do drive over
there kotlin groovy jruby are all
supports out the box
and again for the job of people there's
the ability to write bigger plugins
using Java and therefore have all of the
ID support as well and again all of
that's documented
so if you want to get started uh you can
go to structurizer.com DSL that's the
DSL demo page little text area on the
left multiple diagram Types on the right
hand side a lot of this documentation is
is sitting on GitHub I've listed here
some of the links to the other
alternative rendering engines the one
thing I do want to point you to
is if you go to the DSL GitHub repo
you'll see a link to the DSL cookbook so
I've tried to do here is I've tried to
add a bunch of like here's how you might
do a certain thing with the DSL so
here's an Amazon web services example
um
and it says like here's an example of
how you want to describe your your Cloud
architect with Amazon web services
nice boring gray diagram and perhaps we
can start adding some of the themes and
icons and that sort of stuff so there
are also a bunch of themes I've created
for AWS Azure etc etc which is all
available on that demo page which is
structuralize.com demo and just to show
you that in action here's the AWS
version
so here were the icons
diagram key all generated for you so
this is another nice way to combine all
this tooling and have Cloud architecture
diagrams that also make sense to more
people
so thank you very much uh any questions
yep one here
so the question is if you're using
something like Confluence how do you get
these diagrams and documentation into
Confluence you have a bunch of options
so option one is
you can craft yourself up a CI CD build
process that takes the DSL files
produces a bunch of plant uml files
turns those into PNG files and uploads
them as Confluence so that's that's one
way you kind of have to handcraft the
set steps together I have a an
on-premises installation of the
structurizer tooling which is free it's
open source so the difference between
the light version and the on-premises
version they're both free the vote
they're both open source structurizer
light is like a single workspace at a
time the on-premises version allows you
to to publish or host multiple
workspaces from a single server
installation there are a bunch of
confidence macros I've also built which
are also on GitHub and basically the the
live embedded to Sir HTML iframe in bed
so using the Confluence macros you can
do an iframe embed of that content of
the on-premises installation so that's
option two
option three if you go to
strutrizer.org which is a site it's like
the open source version of all of this
I've linked all of the tools I've found
that have some degree of support for
this tooling there's a company in the
Netherlands called avizi and they have a
collection of Confluence plugins
and they have this thing where if if you
have a structuralized DSL file in a git
repo you can point a Confluence page
to that git repo and it will
automatically render you the file you
pointed at so that's another way to
surface these diagrams in various
formats on confidence pages so yeah you
have a bunch of options essentially
so the question is can you do this with
GitHub and things like mermaid yeah but
you'd have to build your own tool chain
so what many people do is they do GitHub
action look at the DSL file and commit
use the CLI export to mermaid and then
embed it in markdown yep
there's a question over here
yeah so uh the question is is there a
way to link adrs to specific elements
and yes when I showed you the adr's
example it was nested inside the
Software System block if you want to
associate adrs with a container you Nest
the XMR adrs inside the container block
and yeah there's that's all linked to
that element in the model
questions over this side I think I'm
going to ignoring this side but I can't
see any questions over there
yeah
no
uh but feel free to so if you go to
Baxley if you go to backstage's repo
there are some people who are asking
like how do we make structurizer
integration with backstage I I don't
know how to do it and
the thing
the complexity with integration with
backstage is they have a slightly
different version of what a software
system is so you'll have to do some sort
of like bounded contacts Banner context
kind of mapping but yeah it's certainly
possible
but I'm afraid I can't do it for you
it was worth a try any other questions
yeah
what about existing code
yeah so if you have a if you have like
an existing c-sharp.net code base and
you want to automatically generate a
component diagram from it you'll need to
write yourself some tooling that will
use uh dot Nets reflection or some
static analysis techniques
um so I'm not a net developer as you
might have guessed but previously I
believe you could do this for things
like Rosalind does rosin still exist is
it rosin plus plus now so you could you
could you could use those tools to go
and find yourself components in your
code base and then add them to a
container in this in this model
is there any import oh to import
existing diagrams oh no no so if you
have an existing catalog of say C4 plant
your model diagrams there's no way to
convert those to structuralized DSL
any other questions
want to hurt the front yeah
uh so there's there's no way to generate
uh c-sharp components from the
structurizer tooling but you could you
could write that sort of functionality
if you wanted to
but from my perspective this is a go the
other way so if you have an existing
code base you turn that into a diagram
rather than for generating code
cool well thanks very much any more
questions about us don't grab me